hi I'm Eric Voss and Avengers infinity
war was quite a movie and one of the
things that made it so enjoyable to
watch lissa way I've rewarded all of us
hardcore nerds for paying attention
throughout this MZ university it's
packed with subtle little callbacks and
nods who past immoral movies and comics
but also with deeper layers of hidden
meaning that make its shocking
conclusion such a gut punch like a good
punch we need builds character
so let's rewatch infinity warren why not
all interesting details that you might
have missed spoilers ahead if you
haven't seen it yet and let us start
with the opening image over black we
hear a distress call from the as
guardianship as Thanos attacks this is
the same distress called later responded
to by the guardians of the galaxy and
maybe this Asgardian voice sounded
similar to you this is the vocal cameo
by actor director Kenneth Branagh he
directed the first Thor movie then we
move on board this ransacked ship with
ebony maw stepping over dead as
guardians to reaping evany maas a member
of Thanos's black order a squad of
lieutenants who serve him it first
appeared in recent years in the new
avengers comics consisting of Corvus
glaive Proxima midnight ebony ma and
black dwarf who is renamed call obsidian
in this movie colum Citian was the name
of the whole group in the comics there's
also a member named supergiant who was
left out of this movie I made a whole
other video explaining the black order
that you can go check out they anno says
opening monologue lays out his whole
vision that he knows what it feels like
to lose he introduces the core theme of
infinity war sacrifice the bitter cost
that must be paid for victory they an
assist suggests in that as someone who
has made more sacrifices than most that
makes him better fit to survive and more
deserving of his goals and is the
character of this movie who most
aggressively goes after what he wants
this moment established as Thanos as the
protagonists of infinity war really is
your rewatching it you should look at
danos as the hero of this movie is that
historical revisionism
maybe shut up Loki surprises Thanos by
telling them we have a Hulk this is a
callback to Tony Stark's face-to-face
with Loki in the first Avengers I have
an ami we have a Hulk Loki borrowing
Starks line here shows us how far the
previous villain has come he's still the
god of mischief but now there's a
genuine affection for his brother and
his friends notice how when he
introduces himself as Odinson he gives
thora look a sadness for me this echoes
Odin's death and thor ragnarok my sons
I've been waiting for you
Odin finally greeting Loki as his own
blood there was a huge deal for the
black sheep and by calling himself
Odinson here he's calling Thor a true
brother bookies death is a real crushing
way to open the film it lets us know
that the previous favorite villain of
the MCU has been usurped notice how
Thanos tells Thor no resurrections this
time this is a callback to Loki's
history of faking his own death like at
the end of Thor the dark world I'm gonna
think that hoax might have been how Loki
was able to avoid fantasies wrath after
failing him in the Avengers after his
charade was revealed in Ragnarok Loki's
days were pretty much numbered this
scene also features the death of
Heimdall who makes another callback when
he prays to the all fathers to give him
the dark energy to activate the Bifrost
to teleport Hulk to safety look he
actually mentioned the all father's to
Thor in the first Avengers but the
Bifrost gone how much dark energy did
the all-father have to muster to
continue after Thanos escapes with the
space stone hulk crashes back to New
York forming a crater in the sanctum
sanctorum this is a reference to the
Marvel comics when the Silver Surfer
crash-landed in the sanctum warning them
about Thanos meanwhile over in the park
Tony Stark tells Pepper Potts about
dreaming of having a kid named Morgan in
the comics Morgan Stark is actually the
name of Tony's cousin it's interesting
that Tony's so hung up on that sensation
of waking up from dream and momentarily
feeling like it's real his confusing
dreams with reality could be
foreshadowing the film's conclusion
remember an age of Ultron Tony
envisioned a nightmare showing all of
his fellow Avengers dead or maybe just
sleepy now I know the main og Avengers
happen to make it out of this movie fine
but overall Tony's catastrophic
nightmare scenario does become a reality
by the time the credits roll back in the
sanctum Tony butts heads with Doctor
Strange leaning against the cauldron of
the cosmos that cauldron is from the
Doctor Strange comics strange eases it
to help spider-man look backwards in
time
they also joke about Ben and Jerry's
naming ice cream flavors after them
stark raving hazelnuts and a hunka-hunka
burning fudge that's a riff on the Elvis
song a hunka-hunka burning love Tony
mocks strange asking what is your job
exactly besides making blue
this could be a reference to a bit
Benedict Cumberbatch did as Doctor
Strange with Jimmy Kimmel
but strangest responses interesting
protecting your reality douchebag
drained is reminding us that there are
multiple realities a vast multiverse
that he has explored this could be
setting up one possible solution to
ultimately defeating Thanos maybe
bringing the fight into another reality
where the rules of time and space
operate differently
Tony admits he lost track of vision and
Bruce scolds him for losing another
super bot he's referring to Ultron the
super bot whose tech led to visions
creation a process that no matter how
many times i rewatch age of Ultron I
don't think I will ever fully understand
then Tony pulls out this flip phone to
call Steve Rogers this is a callback to
Captain America's Civil War which ended
with cap FedEx Saint Tony's stank letter
and this old man flip phone stay in
touch next we get our first shot of
Peter Parker in this movie with this
close-up of the hairs on his arm
shooting up this is the first instance
in the MCU of spidey-sense parently
spider-man did have it in home come in
we just never saw him use it
it's interesting that the Russos depict
it this way traditionally spider-man's
spidey sense comes from a real-life
spiders actual ability to sense
vibrations through tiny hairs that cover
their bodies so Peters hair sticking up
here is actually grounded in science
making it the only thing in this movie
to have any real scientific basis we get
our traditional cameo from Stan Lee as
the school bus driver and then Peters
t-shirt here has another goofy caption
like all the ones he wore in homecoming
lettuce the taste of sadness that's a
little depressing to rewatch this movie
and know that by the end Peter will
teach us a whole new taste of sadness
the heroes team up to deal with the
chaos caused by the black orders cue
ship and Doctor Strange uses this spell
to reduce the gusty winds his spells
probably the winds of watoomb which is a
move he uses in the comics Tony calls
ebony maw Squidward and Bruce struggles
to summon the big guy leading to this
Jekyll and Hyde face half Bruce half
Hulk which is inspired by art we've seen
the comics before after returning to
Earth Hulk is a real no-show an infinity
war we did see him running in a big
splashy marathon shot in the trailer
which I suspected would not be in the
final movie it definitely wasn't but the
reason for hoax performance anxiety is
that in the opening scene Hulk
straight-up lost in a fight for the
first time ever now in past movies he
definitely took beatings but they knows
knocked him out cold that's got to be
quite an existential shock to whole so
he's either afraid or just too proud he
doesn't wanna get knocked out again in
this sequence we also got a look at Iron
Man's new nanotech armor called bleeding
edge and the comic starts bleeding edge
armor comes out of nanobots in his blood
assembly and out of his skin here it
looks more similar to Black Panthers
vibranium armor it stems out of a
central node and then pieces together
around his body during the fight every
ma tries to snatch dr. Strange's I've AG
Emoto but a protective spell burns his
hand this could be a nod to Raiders of
the Lost Ark the neck nazi guy totes
tries to steal the staff of raw
headpiece and it burns his hand leaving
the scar MA and Thoth are definitely
pretty parallel they speak in Chilean
high-pitched voices they seem to love
torturing people and they have an epic
death and then after Peter Parker gets
his new iron spider armor so cool Stark
activate this parachute saying Happy
Trails he's quoting die hard when Bruce
Willis pulls one of the best behind the
back switcheroos in movie history okay
moving on to the guardians of the galaxy
the song they're listening to is
rubberband man by the Detroit spinners
this track is actually from yondu Zune
which Peter quill picked up at the end
of volume 2 teenage Groot is playing a
handheld video game defender this was an
arcade game also an Atari 2600 game this
could be a nod to the defenders one of
the few Marvel's screen adaptations not
otherwise to make it into this movie a
lot of the game also involves defending
Earth from alien so it's a pretty
appropriate choice the Guardians run
into Thor leading to some pretty amazing
comedy between the Chris's I should
point out that Thor reports that Thanos
slaughtered half of his Asgardian
survivors to me it looked like all of
them poor dead but if we take Thor at
his word Valkyrie Korg and meek who were
all on that ship at the end of Ragnarok
might have been among those survivors
Thor rocket and Groot split off to
nineveh leer which is a place in the
Marvel comics it's one of the Asgardian
nine worlds along with Asgard it's where
their weaponry comes from it's cool we
actually get to see this place in the
movie until now Thor has mentioned that
his hammer Mjolnir was forged in the
heart of a dying star but invented to
work confirms that he meant a literal
dying star we get to see that star in
action if you were blacksmith you've
probably really dug this plotline if you
didn't it's always fun to hear
or call rockets rabbit definitely one of
my favorite running jokes in these
movies
that's how eyesight works you stupid
raccoon I'm sorry I took it too far
I meant trash bandit jumping over to
vision and Scarlet Witch in Scotland
when they looked through a restaurant
window notice a sign we will deep-fry
your kebab that's a joke about
Scotland's tendency to deep-fry all of
their food it sounds like a magical
place then when Corvus glaive
approximate midnight attack the fight
spills over to this metro station where
Captain America makes his awesome
entrance with the opening beat of the
Avengers theme music notice how his look
has changed in the two years since Civil
War it's darker he's got a beard in his
suit no longer has the classic white
star emblem caps whole look here is
modeled on the Nomad run of the
character in the marvel comics when Kap
becomes a soldier without a country but
if you look really closely at a suit at
air shows that he's still wearing that
older scale armor underneath so even
though the guy looks different hasn't
completely change his identity this
fight ends with black widows cold
promise we don't want to kill you
oh we will and próximo responds you'll
never get the chance again I love how
this sets up their confrontation later
when Proxima nearly kills Natasha but
then it's curly which lists her to get
wiped out by one of those big tank
things then after gamora's flashback
showing her becoming a child of Thanos
we arrive at nowhere among the
collectors collection is this blue man
on the left this is a reference to the
show Arrested Development which the
directors the Russo brothers used to
work on I've actually done this before
putting a Bluth family stair truck in
the background of the airport battle in
civil war this is a nod to the tobias
gag where he was trying to join the blue
man group and then he stalked his wife
by blending in with blue backgrounds
hello they included the detail of its
never-nude Jean cut-offs there's another
really fun reference when Thanos
interrogate the collector played by
Benicio del Toro
notice how Ana's asks for the reality
stone
to stone Thanos is doing an impression
of Del Toro's character in the movie
snatch Franky four fingers who was a
jewel thief maybe the reason vanna's
knows this is because he actually
already has the reality stone can look
into other realities notice how he uses
of gaudi stone to turn Drax in the
blocks and mantis in the ribbons this is
a reference to Thanos in the comics when
he uses the reality gem to do this to
nebula in Star Fox aka eros then after
star-lord calls that his grimace he
tries to make good on his promise to
Gamora to kill her if she ever gets
captured
but Thanos turns his blasts into bubbles
this could be a nod to Thanos in the
Marvel vs. Capcom games where one of his
moves was to trap people in a bubble
back in Avengers HQ black widow explains
why Hawkeye and ant-man are not in this
movie Clint is with his family Scott is
on house arrest vision proposes that
Scarlet Witch destroy the mind stone in
his forehead arguing that one life
shouldn't stand in the way of half the
universe the cap refuses saying we don't
trade lives again infinity war is
touching back on that whole theme of
sacrifice what do you lose by winning is
the cost worth it and then when cap
suggests that he knows a place to hide
vision you may recognize the music the
sound you're hearing is the talking drum
used by composer LED big bjornsen in the
Black Panther score so we move on to a
condo where to chala meets with Bucky
calling him the white wolf now we heard
kids calling him white wolf in a
post-credits scene for black panther new
Marvel Comics white wolf is a separate
character he was a white kid adopted by
two challahs father who later became the
character hunter who led the covert ops
war dogs group
sounds like the movies could be merging
the characters or at least using white
wolf as uh what kind of nickname for
Bucky meanwhile back on empty mosque you
ship we see him torturing dr. strange is
another detail pulled from the Marvel
comics epidemis trains in the comics
which is a huge defeat considering
strange is the most powerful mind in the
Marvel world
spider-man pitches a plan to save
strange based on the movie alien calling
it a really old movie this is a callback
to the way he took inspiration from the
Empire Strikes Back to bring down
ant-man in Civil War
his plan here it turns out is exactly
how ripley defeats the xenomorph at the
end of a lien as well as a xenomorph
queen and aliens blow the sucker out of
space
every ma even makes the same angry pose
as he floats away that the alien queen
did at the innovations leader Peters
screams at mantis to not lay eggs inside
I'm referencing the xenomorph
facehuggers who incubate offspring
inside the hosts first have their chests
during the fight with ebony ma the iron
spider suit releases these spider legs
these are from the Marvel Civil War
comics they're called Waldo's and I'm so
glad that the movie left these out of
the trailers and let them as a surprise
Peter shouts what are those which is a
callback to sharees line of black
panther is well with the reference in
the mean back on banisters ship he shows
Gamora how he's torturing nebula with
this cool shot rotating around to show
how she's been pulled out in two pieces
now famous torturers nebula and the
Infinity Gauntlet comics but it's even
more graphic there he basically burns
her and forces her to stay alive Gamora
seen nebulas various machine parts all
splayed out echoes nebula explaining her
cruel upbringing to crackland and
guardians the galaxy vol 2 every time my
sister prevailed
my father would replace a piece of me
with machinery but she won again and
again and again never once refraining so
this image reminds Gamora of her guilt
for doing this to her sister and it
motivates why she concedes to take
damage to the soul stone meanwhile with
Thor's group rocket gives Thor this
replacement I this is a callback to
Rockets weird interest in stolen body
parts specifically the ravager I that
he's stolen Guardians volume 2
Ziya isn't that same one exactly rocket
says that he found this one on contrack
SIA which was the frozen planet that we
saw in that movie then they arrive at
Nitta Valley R where they meet Peter
Dinklage's character he plays a tree the
king of the dwarves they work as
foragers and blacksmiths he is their
sole survivor each we reveals that
Thanos forced him to build the Infinity
Gauntlet and he blames Thor for not
protecting him and his people this
actually answers a key question that has
kept coming up why did Tanis only attack
now what has he been waiting for
well the answer is a way to contain all
the Infinity stones
he couldn't wield all of them together
without this gauntlet it was forged in
the heat of the same dying star that
produced Mjolnir for ages Nineveh Lear
was protected by a scarred but recent
events change that Odin went missing and
Loki basically allowed the nine realms
to fall into chaos
then in Thor Ragnarok Odin died hello
return and that eventually resulted in
the complete obliteration of Asgard all
of this left knit a valley open to
attack allowing Fanus to get the one
tool he needed to really move forward
with his infinity plot now this does
kind of present a bit of a timeline
hiccup because we did see Thanos put on
that gauntlet in the post-credits scene
after age of Ultron but maybe we can
assume that scene took place after
Thanos sacked middle ear following the
events of Ragnarok the new hammer that a
tree forges for Thor is called storm
breaker which is another Marvel Comics
reference that's the name of the battle
axe carried by beta ray bill it was a
korbinite version of Thor Groot breaking
off his arm branch to form the handle of
Stormbreaker was such a badass moment
and it actually presents a question
Groot is of course among the ones who
fade away at the end of this movie but
in the past if even as much as a twig of
him survives a nuke root could
theoretically form so can a new Groot
form out of the handle of storm breaker
well that would make for a really fun
reveal for Thor may the strength of the
old fathers angry puh-leeze meanwhile on
Titan the Guardians meet Tony's group
and devise their own plan against Thanos
Drax suggests a dance hop to save the
universe which is a reference to Star
Lords dance-off with Ronan at the end of
the first Guardians spider-man compares
this to Footloose star Lords favorite
movie calling back mantis bringing up
Kevin Bacon as Earth's Mightiest hero
earlier in the movie while they argue
Doctor Strange uses the time stone to
look in the future at over 14 million
different timelines where the Avengers
win and only one of them now I have a
lot of thoughts about what that timeline
is and how all of dr. Strange's actions
from this point forward like trading the
time stone for Tony Stark's life saying
we are in the endgame now and his final
words being this was the only way all
this could be a part of dr. strange a
specific plan but I'm actually making
another video that digs into all of
those theories so stay tuned let's move
on to Boromir the resting place of the
soul stone Boromir is another location
the marble
it's home to a race of beings called
forms their giant dragon lizard things
at travel galaxy looking for planets to
feast on but the biggest shocker on this
planet was a cameo by Red Skull huh
Red Skull works was the villain of the
first Captain America movie except he's
not being played here by Hugo Weaving
this is actor Ross Marquand he's a
skilled impressionist and Aaron from The
Walking Dead where he does a wonderful
impression of caring about his
characters storylines we last saw Red
Skull trying to harness the tesseract
but the power of the space stone sucked
him into the cosmos he explains to
Thanos Saint Gamora that he wasn't
deemed worthy to wield the space stone
so now he has to serve as a keeper of
the soul stone his hooded appearance
might possibly be meant to evoke
mistress death from the Infinity
Gauntlet comics the cosmic entity
Thanos's in love with and does
everything for you listen closely red
school references a Lars Lars is an
eternal in the Marvel Comics it's the
name of Thanos his father this whole
moment is perhaps the movie's most
emotional example of that sacrifice
theme that I mentioned before this idea
of a soul for a soul having to give up
someone you love it's an archetypal
story beat that we've seen over and over
again in mythology in the Bible Abraham
has to sacrifice his son Isaac before it
last minute just kidding from God and in
the game of Thrones book series The
Legend of azor Ahai required him to
plunge his sword into the heart of his
wife miss Anissa to forge Lightbringer
it's this moment that Thanos becomes
more than a simple villain it truly
breaks his heart to kill Gamora and
afterward he returns to Titan and talks
with dr. strange about his motivations
vanna's uses the reality stone his show
strange Titans utopian past before
overpopulation destroyed its environment
now this is a major change from Thanos's
back story in the comics which cast of
him is a young loner and pacifist who
fell in love with a female embodiment of
death had led him on a vengeful killing
spree here he's more of an eco-terrorist
protecting the universe from itself it's
honestly not too different from Ultron
Doctor Strange asks him what he'll do
after wiping out half the universe and
he responds finally rest and watch the
Sun rise on a grateful universe now not
to throw too many religious metaphors at
you but vanos is casting himself as a
god figure despite Loki promising him
that he would never be won in Thanos's
eyes his story is not one of destruction
it's a creation story in fact the one
from Jenna
the six Infinity stones could reflect
these six days it took God to build the
universe and Thanos resting to watch the
Sun rise could reflect that seventh day
in which God rested the fights that
follows includes a few interesting
visual references spider-man web Stannis
in the face which is movie pulls in the
comics Doctor Strange also uses a few
familiar spells the crimson bands of
cyttorak red lassos a mystical energy
from the comics looks like he tries to
trap dennis in the mirror dimension
which is something we saw the ancient
one do - kycilia sin the Doctor Strange
movie then Doctor Strange makes this
interesting multi-armed pose that's also
inspired by art from the Doctor Strange
comics it leads to strange spitting off
dozens of copies of himself which looks
like in the comics which he replicates
himself over and over again
strangest pose also resembles the Hindu
figure Durga the goddess of war Durga
translates to invincible so maybe dr.
strange is using this imagery to
intimidate Thanos but Thanos isn't
fooled he knows which strange is a real
one this could be a benefit of having
the reality stone or the soul stone some
of you also asked about Thanos
recognizing stark and saying you're not
the only one cursed with knowledge so
maybe this means that acquiring the soul
stone connected Thanos to all the souls
of the universe knowing where each of
them are and everything about them or
maybe Thanos just remembers the [__]
who popped up into a wormhole from Earth
and nuked his army mmm also you might
have noticed how nebula crashes a party
in a necrocraft this is the same kind of
ship that we saw in the first guardians
of the galaxy really it was just awesome
to see this team combine their strength
to restrain Thanos merely close enough
to slip the gauntlet off his hand
that is until star-lord ruined it by
flipping out over Thanos killing Gamora
allowing baños to escape their grasp now
we actually went into whether everything
was star Lords fault in another video
but pre watching the movie you could
place the blame for theses victory on a
lot of characters Tony insisted on
taking a cue ship to Titan to confront
Thanos even though dr. strange wanted to
turn back and keep the time stone away
from him
Thor used Stormbreaker to hit Thanos in
his chest so that he could look him in
the eyes as he avenged his Asgardian
fallen
instead of just killing Tanis
immediately with a head shot then yeah a
cap and Skaar the witch banner the
others insisted on finding a way to
remove the mine stone from vision
without killing him
when vision just wanted it done right
away this allowed Panos to rewind
time just a few seconds to retrieve it
intact in the final moments basically
you could play this what-if game
endlessly but it'll be interesting to
see if this survivor's guilt of bex any
of the others in the next movie but let
us talk about this final battle on
Wakanda it begins with this prophetic
line from T'Challa to Proxima Thanos
we'll have nothing but dust and blood
black panther doesn't yet realize it but
that's exactly what ends up happening he
and several others end up turning in the
dust and for blood yeah you could argue
that it might refer to that one drop of
blood that start gets out of his face on
Titan as they line up for battle
T'Challa and his troops chant a bombe
which is the word in South African
language of Xhosa which wakandan is
based on translate into hold fast or
hold strong the forearmed foot soldiers
that they fight are called out writers
they're pretty beastly and animalistic
in this movie but in the comics they're
genetically engineered assassins that
can turn invisible and read people's
minds while they sleep in the yoke
indeed charge against these guys we see
cap and Black Panther sprinting out
ahead of the frontline this echoes their
superfast foot chase in Civil War and
it's just satisfying to see them running
side by side this time like their goals
are aligned thor's entrance in this
battle is truly epic it's one of the
moments and I think is really justified
statement up and clapping as you're
watching the movie it definitely recalls
is god of thunder returning Ragnarok but
if you look closely it appears that he
uses the Bifrost to bring himself here
that's interesting this could mean
Stormbreaker possesses the power of the
Bifrost remember while he held open that
Forge he did pray to the all fathers to
give him strength so perhaps this whole
new weapon allows him to teleport from
place to place D we get a few more great
pairings Bucky lifts rocket to spin
around as he lights up the outriders
this is a callback to guardians when
rocket does this with Groot afterward
rocket asks Bucky how much for the harm
chuckling say no I'm gonna get that arm
this is another callback to guardians
when Rocket jokingly requested that he
wanted that guy's prosthetic leg but all
their efforts are for naught because the
mad Titan arrives and he takes all of
them out one by one little design detail
that I really liked here when Fantas
rewinds time to assemble the mine stone
he rotates his gauntlet counterclockwise
I guess that was the same direction in
dr. strange I just don't really notice
that tell me then baños does exactly
what we all feared he
snaps his fingers he actually does it
Marvel Studios you crazy bastards this
twist of course was pulled directly from
the Infinity Gauntlet Comics Thanos
actually goes through with it there too
and it's every bit as dramatic half the
universe fades away here watching it
happen to these big screen faces we've
gotten to know and love over the past
decade no man does it hurts
Bucky wakandans soldiers Black Panther
Groot Scarlet Witch Falcon and then on
Titan mantis Drax Peter quill Doctor
Strange and then a post-credits scene
there's Nick Fury and Maria Hill but the
saddest one of all is Peter Parker not
to make you feel worse guys but notice
how he says mr. stark I don't feel so
well and the rest of the characters are
pretty much confused by what's going on
but Peter feels sick to his stomach
that's because his spidey sense is
alerting him that the end is near so
rather than confusion Peter's final
moments are spent in fear and agony and
panic it's actually kind of poetic
considering his opening frame showed his
spidey sense as do his closing moments
he'll guys even the title the movie
fades away during the credits also if
you're curious about where Thanos went
the moment he snapped his fingers my
best guess is sole world that's a plane
associated with soulstone in the comics
Sam basher and I had made other videos
that kind of taken to that more actually
this moment reminded me a lot of the
final Harry Potter movie when Harry uses
the resurrection stone and enters into a
hazy otherworldly realm where he meets
with the spirit of Dumbledore before
returning to the real world could have
been a coincidence but maybe the soul
stone has a similar power if they a
knows happened to be in the half of the
universe I got wiped out in that snap
way perhaps the soul stone is what
resurrected him the final image of the
movie shows Thanos making good on that
promise to dr. strange to rest and watch
the Sun Rise
he no longer wears his armor or the
Infinity Gauntlet actually if you look
closely in the corner you can see his
armor hang up that's a reference to the
Infinity Gauntlet comics in which Thanos
retires on a farm hanging up his armor
on a scarecrow it's actually not clear
if the gauntlet is there as well it
looked pretty fried and broken up after
the snap so hopefully that means again
snap away another 25% of the universe
but as of now the remaining survivors
are Iron Man Captain America Thor Banner
Black Widow war machine nebula rocket
Ocoee a mbaku ensure Ian Wong I think I
think Hawkeye a man and the wasp were
out there and yes so was Captain Marvel
as we learned the post
see and go check out my breakdown video
of that yes this was super shocking to
see the movie end with such a bleak
cliffhanger but if we're being us with
ourselves this was a promise Marvel has
been making since the beginning not just
with the moment the Infinity Gauntlet
comics the movies have gradually been
warning us about this there was Tony's
lying to Loki in the first Avengers
because if we can't protect the Earth
you can be damn well sure we'll avenge
it then in a second Avengers movie age
of Ultron we learned that these movies
are actually willing to kill off an
Avenger and it left us with that
haunting image of Tony's nightmare and
also gave us this warning
we'll lose and we'll do that together
too and then the last two MC movies to
lead into this one made us grow up a
little Thor Ragnarok ended by following
through on the promise of its premise by
actually destroying Asgard while people
watched helplessly shortly after that
black panther forced us to actually
empathize with a villain to see the
logic and an evil plan both movies helps
prepare us for Thanos a villain with an
empathetic apocalyptic plan that we were
just helpless to watch but just as
Thanos his sacrifice made him stronger
the losses of the Avengers will make
them stronger too inspiring them to
fulfill the promise of their identities
to avenge now you may still have a lot
of questions about Infinity Warren we've
already started to answer a lot of them
that have come up in our heads with
other videos like what happens in this
movies ending and the post-credits scene
how exactly does this whole stone work
and what are the ways that the Avengers
could fight back in the next movie where
is Hawkeye go watch all those videos on
those subjects but we also got even more
questions to dig into in the pipeline
like how much of this defeat was part of
the timeline that dr. strange foresaw
and what exactly was his plan and what
exactly happened to the characters who
appeared to die can they come back and
who else might have died that we didn't
see but a question I want to leave you
with is which of the surviving
characters do you think will survive the
final confrontation with Thanos and
Avengers 4 comment down below to let me
know your thoughts and thank you to our
sponsors Skillshare for helping us make
this video skills share is an online
learning community with thousands of
classes and design business technology
and more it's premium membership gives
you unlimited access to high-quality
classes on must-know topics so you can
improve your skills unlock new
opportunities and do the work you love
the work I love is writing and the
hardest
part of writing for me is commitment to
a routine so I really love Simon van
bouys writers toolkit six steps to a
successful writing habit his steps were
really helpful and helping me be more
productive so if you do any creative
work I highly recommend it Skillshare is
also more affordable than most learning
platforms out there an annual
subscription is less than ten dollars a
month but we're even gonna do a special
offer for you guys the first 500 people
to sign up with the link in the
description below will get their first
two months for free just go to sk l dot
sh / new rockstars 3 or click on the
link in the description for all of you
you can tweet me directly at EF I knew
rockstars on Twitter for updates on our
videos like and share this video
subscribe to the rockstars for all of
our coverage on Avengers infinity war
thanks for watching everybody